earlier this year the house judiciary
committee approved a bill called h.r 40.
if passed it would establish a
commission to study giving reparations
to black people to compensate to
compensate for the institution of
slavery but what are reparations exactly
and what should they make up for let's
find out in a segment called how did we
get here
[Music]
when many americans hear the word
reparations they think of it as a
monetary compensation for the emotional
impact of slavery kind of like a check
with i'm sorry written in the memo but
that's not what reparations are because
there is no amount of money you could
pay that would make up for enslaving
people
the actual purpose of reparations is to
restore the physical and financial
things that were stolen from black
americans as a result of slavery there
are lots of examples of this but let's
just explore one housing and to do that
let's go back to the year 1865.
that's when bicycles looked like this
and paul rudd looked like this
right before the civil war ended
president lincoln's top general met with
a group of black ministers to ask how
the government could help the formerly
enslaved be successful in america they
said give us some land we can live on
and the general said no problem we have
a bunch we just stole from native
americans
the general issued special field order
number 15 which confiscated confederate
land and gave it back to black people
the government promised every formerly
enslaved black family 40 acres and a
mule which is very practical personally
i would have asked for 40 acres and a
hippopotamus just mess with them
unfortunately what the government didn't
promise was no take backsies because
after lincoln's assassination president
andrew johnson rescinded the order and
left those black families without a
place to live because just like a dental
patient swearing they're gonna start
flossing the u.s loves to go back on a
promise now let's skip ahead to the
1930s and 40s that's when cars looked
like this and paul rudd looked like this
at that time black americans were being
terrorized in the south so millions of
them migrated north but many northerners
refused to rent or sell homes to them so
black families did what they've done for
generations they made something out of
nothing they created makeshift
communities and alleyways in cities like
washington dc and then congress came
along and created something called the
alleyway dwelling authority they cited
the eighth article of the constitution
which is if things are going okay for
black people it's time to [ __ ] it up
the alleyway dwelling authority said we
love what you've done with the place but
we want to make it safe for you why
don't you move out and let us fix it up
for you but when they did they put those
houses up for sale at prices so high
black families couldn't afford to move
back so they were left once again
without a place to live now usually when
something that bad happens to black
people it's because somebody said the
word candyman five times
hold on did that count as one of my
times i'll take it back
no the history of kicking black people
out of their homes isn't limited to big
cities let's look at a town in maryland
called frostburg in 1866 two black women
purchased land there that no one else
wanted and with it they created
brownsville a community of freed black
people they built a school and a
flourishing community of businesses and
homes owned by black people i think you
know where this is going the local white
people saw what could be done on that
land and they decided they wanted a
school too and you guessed it they built
it right on top of brownsville they
spent the next couple of decades pushing
black residents out of their homes so
that they could build a college in fact
members of the community were forced to
sell their houses for ten dollars ten
dollars for a house is insane even
monopoly houses cost fifty
the only house that should cost ten
dollars is this one and even then you're
underpaying it's adorable
so what used to be brownsville is now
frostburg state university whose mascot
is i'm guessing the sneaky land thieves
and the university left the residents of
brownsville and their descendants
without a place to live which brings us
back to reparations reparations aren't
just about putting a monetary value on
the harm of enslavement they're about
restoring to black americans the
tangible things that were stolen from
them through jim crow laws housing
discrimination and so many other living
breathing legacies to enslavement and
there is no limit to what these
reparations can look like maybe it's
direct payments maybe it's housing
subsidies maybe it's buying 17 copies of
the book i wrote with my sister lacey
i'm just spitballing here
whatever we do
it's time to do something that bill i
mentioned earlier h.r 40 it was written
in 1989 and has been introduced in every
session of congress since which means
it's 32 years old that's right they've
been trying to pass this bill for an
entire daniel kaluya
let's pass it already so our country can
become something better than it has been
for the past 400 years because if we
don't well then america much like this
guy's face might just stay exactly like
this forever this has been how do we get
here
[Applause]
[Music]
you